so I decided to walk through a
restaurant to have a nice dinner and
then when I came out of the restaurant I
saw that it was absolutely chucking it
down me rain I got like a one-mile walk
home and at first I was waiting for the
rain to die down before I walked out the
out of the restaurant and then I went
and he was spitting a bit and I was
trying to get under the trees I was
worried about the getting soaking wet
and then it kind of gets to a point
where you just say you know what I'm
drenched I can feel my my socks or
slushy I'm wet it's good and you kind of
get past the point of caring about you
being wet and you just step out and you
begin to almost enjoy the rain and you
know right now I'm just I'm enjoying
this I'm enjoying the rain because I
know when I get home I'm gonna get
changed I'm gonna jump in the bath and
all's good and I feel like in the exact
same way so many people that I see
starting out in prophecy there are best
scared to get wet they're scared to fail
they're scared to look stupid they're
scared to be rejected so what they do is
they just sort of stand there inside the
restaurant inside their homes watching
my youtube videos worries to step out
and fail worry to step out and get wet
and you know what until you get to the
point where boy you're happy to fail but
boy you're happy to get wet you know
what you just know that's gonna happen
you just get a stay inside when you get
to the point where you're happy to fail
you're happy to get wet you're happy to
look stupid what happens is you become
dangerous in the marketplace you become
dangerous because suddenly you're not
worried about what the estate agents
think you're not worried about looking a
bit [ __ ] you know worried about your
friends and family finding out that your
improv insane yeah here you're gonna
enjoy the rain so right now you know I'm
at home now I'm not even gonna bother
running inside I'm just gonna stand out
enjoy a little bit more rain before I go
back in and I used to do the same
get happy being wet get happy failing
get happy looking stupid be comfortable
being uncomfortable because until you
can enjoy failing you're never gonna
succeed and I want to turn this off
before my phone dies with the rain you
want to come and enjoy some rain you
want stay inside see Doug Doug don't be
safe like a man
enjoy the rain hey BAE you want to come
enjoy the rain
No